الانباء تشير الى ان المساحه التي سيقت
تعها الجيش الاسرائيلي لانشاء المنطقه
العازله التي يتحدث عنها ا ستكون تقريبا
نصف مساحه قطاع غزه هل يعد ذلك في تقديرك
اعاده احتلال للقطاع اذا كانت هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه ستستمر
لعامين ا محمود هذا هو الهدف ولكن القدره
في التنفيذ اثنين القدره في
اي فعلا تامين الامن لغلاف غزه على سبيل
المثال عندما كان السياج الذكي وهو الذي
كلف 1.1 مليار دولار واستعمل فيه اسمنت
يكفي لبناء طريق من قطاع غزه الى بلغاريا
ا مجهز باحدث العتاد الاساسي كان ايضا
لديه منطقه عازله كيلومتر ا داخل قطاع غزه
يمكن ل فقط للمزارعين ان يدخلوها وعلى
مسافه 100 متر ممنوع لاحد ان يدخل هذه
المناطق وبالتالي حصلت 7 اكتوبر اليوم
الحلول التي يبتكرها ايه يعني جيش
الاحتلال او الحكومه الاسرائيليه هي حلول
تقريبا مؤقته دائما الحل هو في السياسه
ولكن في العسكر يجب اولا ان توقف القذائف
يعني ف لو سلمنا جدلا انك بنيت هذه
المنطقه العازله هذه المنطقه العازله مع
صواريخ مع حماس مع صواريخ مع المقاومه صير
ظل هذا الامر يعني قادر على ضرب كل هذه
المنظومه الامنيه ا اقوى واحدث منظومه
امنيه كانت في غلاف غزه وسقطت في يوم
واحد طيب ما الذي يعني ما الذي يضمن
القبول لهذه الخطه في ظل الظرف الحرج الذي
يواجهه نتنياهو سياسيا في هذه المرحله و
يعني كم عدد الجنود الذين سيتطلب توفيرهم
لتامين هذه المنطقه العازله على النحو
الذي تقول اسرائيل انها تعمل عليه في ظل
الاخبار عن تسريح مئات الالاف من جنود
الاحتياط لنتنياهو اهداف كبرى وضعها بعد 7
اكتوبر
اييه الانهاء حركه حماس ضرب المقاومه ولكن
هذا الامر لم يترجم عسكريا على الارض
لتحقيق الاهداف التي وضعها نتنياهو اليوم
عندما تريد فعلا ان ت يعني تقوم ب بناء
منطقه عازله اولا لا تزال شمال غزه جزء
اساسي من هذه العمليه بين الشجاعيه بين
جباليا بين الشيخ رضوان بين التفاح وما
شابه اثنين هناك الوسط في منطقه غزه ثلاثه
لا تزال خان يونس حتى ولو تم تطويقها الى
حد ما من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه لا تزال
فاعله وقادره يعني لا تزال القوات
المقاومه قادره على قيام بعمليات
عمليات مقاومه ضد الاحتلال يعني انت اذا
قررت ان تنظف مكانا ما من العسكر يجب عليك
في المرحله الثانيه ان تسيطر عليه وهذا
امر صعب جدا لماذا ماذا عن الانفاق ماذا
عن القدرات التي تتحدث عنها يعني هذه هذا
الموضوع بعيد بعيد التحقيق في المرحله
الحاليه ما يطلبه الامريكيون لنصف يناير
الانتقال الى المرحله ذات الحده المنخفضه
للحرب يعني
تطويق تطويق مدينه غزه السيطره على الوسط
وبالتالي تطويق مدينه خانيونس والتعامل
معها بشكل من الاشكال وهذا ما قد يبنى
عليه على انه منطقه عازله ولكن ماذا عن
الحلول الباقيه هل هل يترافق مع هذه الخطط
استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي على الاحياء
التي يقطنها المدنيون بهذه الوتيره التي
نشهدها
الان
هذا هو القلق الامريكي من هذا الموضوع مع
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سلمت
اسرائيل 5000 قنبله وزن 2000 باوند ثمن
القنبله الواحده
16000 دولار امريكي اليوم نتحدث عن هذا
الموضوع هذا هو القلق الامريكي لانه
امريكا بدات تخسر صورتها والقيم الخاصه
التي تقول عنها وايضا اسرائيل بدات تفقد
هذا الدعم الدولي الذي اخذته 7 اكتوبر
المرحله القادمه هي مرحله الاستطلاع
الاستخبارات الاستعلام التكت والقيام
بعمليات محدوده مركزه على مكان ما وهذا
امر اعتقد انه ياخذ الكثير من السنوات
وتعودنا عليه في جنوب لبنان طيب اذا دخلنا
في عقل المقاومه ما الاجراءات التي يمكن
ان نشهدها من قبل القسام وفصائل المقاومه
المسلحه الاخرى ردا على هذا التخطيط
الاسرائيلي
دائما في عمليات المقاومه خاصه ان حماس
ليست مرتبطه جغرافيا بداع خارجي رئيسي
دائما هو الاستمرار محمود دائما تربح حماس
اذا استمرت بالقتال ولم تقبل ب وقف النار
عندما تقول لحماس اذا سلمتني الرهائن سوف
اقضي عليك في اليوم الثاني هذا الامر صعب
وعدم قبول حماس والمقاومه بوقف النار الذي
اقترحته اسرائيل منذ اربعه خمسه ايام يدل
على انها لا تزال قادره على القتال لتحسين
شروطها ان كان في موضوع الرهائن
والكل مقابل الكل او حتى في موضوع
الاستمرار في المرحله ما بعد انتهاء الحرب
يعني الصمود اللوجستيه العسكر وبالتالي
الحفاظ على القياده والسيطره اذا حللنا
بهذه الصوره اذا حللنا مواقف جميع الاطراف
نجد ان الاطراف كل كلها في ورطه تقريبا
ورطه عسكريه وورطه سياسيه
واستراتيجيه دخول دخول اسرائيل الى منطقه
الى الى الى غزه اذا استكملت اسرائيل
عملياتها العسكريه هي تخسر واذا تراجعت هي
تخسر هي خاسر خاسر في كل الاحوال اليوم
الشيء المهم هو استمرار وصمود لربح مرحله
الوقت يعني الوقت عامل اساسي بالنسبه
للمقاومه هذه الخسائر وسحب كتيبه من
اللواء جولاني شيء مؤشر لمرحله لاحقه
السعي لتحرير ال الاحتياط هذا شيء ايضا
اساسي المشكله السياسيه في الداخل
الاسرائيلي شيء اساسي الحرب
تكلف اسرائيل تقريبا 270 مليون دولار
يوميا حتى الان الخسائر اسرائيليه تقدر ب
50 مليار واليوم بدانا فتح جبهات كثيره
على اسرائيل وهذا ما يمكن القول على انه
المثل الصيني الموت ب 100
طعنه